tulsi gabbard a sort of democrat i don't
know is she still a democrat i guess she
is
chelsea gabbard pointed this out the
other day when the mayor of chicago lori
lightfoot came out
and said that she's only going to give
interviews to black journalists only
one-on-one interviews
to black and brown journalists you think
uh
what huh you can't do that well tulsi
tweets out quote
mayor lightfoot's blatant anti-white
racism is abhorrent i call upon
president biden
kamala harris and other leaders of our
country of all races to join me in
calling for mayor lightfoot's
resignation
our leaders must condemn all racism
including anti-white
oh my goodness the pushback she got
you're not allowed to say that
because what what the radical left says
is you can't
you can't be racist against white people
and i suppose they would make the same
argument about asians but that's a
little
tricky for them to make right now so
they mostly just talk about the white
people so you can't be
racist against white people because they
redefine racism as they always do you
know
the left wields power in many ways by
redefining the words if you control the
words you control the culture which is
by the way the subtitle of my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now of
course for
pre-order hello do we uh where's that do
we get a
ding there we go okay good good i just
want to make sure
that that bell comes up so kamala hara
says look anti-white racism is a big
problem too
yes of course it is but they say that
racism
is sort of discrimination and the
judgment plus
power and they define the power as being
whiteness they say that we're in white
supremacism right they just begin it's
so talk about circular arguments getting
back to dr fauci
they say it's ju therefore it's just not
possible it only runs in one direction
that's just a standard that's just their
their standard that they're going to
enforce
and it's a racial hierarchy and it's a
caste system you're seeing this play out
not just
in the traditional racial division
that radicals try to gin up in this
country namely the division between
blacks and whites you're seeing it also
now specifically
in this israel issue so there's
looks like things are calming down over
there in israel but
this flare-up was notable
in that you had a real party-line
division here
the left the democrats supported the
palestinian arabs one against israel
the conservatives and the republicans
generally supported israel and that was
the dividing line
why is that it's because of the exact
same
vision it's the the exact same racial
political
ideology yo ring that bell
like and subscribe also though while
i've got you while i've got your
attention
i know you're on youtube head on over to
apple podcast
spotify google play wherever you listen
to your podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show
we want to avoid all sorts of
shenanigans that the big tech companies
play
we want to make sure you are always
getting those updates
if you wouldn't mind leave a five-star
review we sure do like that i very much
appreciate that we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you